قد يجبر جائحة الفيروس التاجي الطلاب الدوليين على مغادرة الولايات المتحدة ، وتقول سلطات الهجرة والجمارك الأمريكية إن حاملي تأشيرة الطلاب سيضطرون إلى العودة إلى ديارهم أو مواجهة الترحيل إذا تم تحويلهم إلى دراسات عبر الإنترنت ، كما لن يتم إصدار تأشيرات طلابية جديدة ببيان صحفي من تقول سلطات إنفاذ قوانين الهجرة والجمارك الأمريكية إن وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية لن تصدر تأشيرات للطلاب المسجلين في المدارس و / أو البرامج المتصلة بالإنترنت بالكامل لفصل الخريف ولن تسمح لنا الجمارك وحماية الحدود هؤلاء الطلاب بدخول الولايات المتحدة مراسل العدالة CNN تنضم إلي جيسيكا شنايدر الآن من واشنطن بمزيد من المعلومات حول هذا الإعلان العديد من الطلاب في جميع أنحاء الولايات المتحدة وأولئك الذين في الخارج ينتظرون الدخول في حالة من الاضطراب هنا تمامًا. موقف محفوف بالمخاطر لأنه إذا كانت هذه الجامعات فقط  قم بإجراء هذه الفصول الدراسية عبر الإنترنت ، وإذا
لم يكن لدى الطلاب الدوليين
أي فصول شخصية للذهاب إليها
، فسيتعين عليهم مغادرة هذا البلد أو
المخاطرة بالترحيل التي كانت بمثابة التوجيهات
الصادرة عن سلطات الهجرة والجمارك
بالأمس فقط وتأتي في نفس
الوقت
أن العديد من الجامعات في جميع أنحاء
البلاد تعلن عن خططها
لإعادة الافتتاح في
جامعة هارفارد الخريفية على سبيل المثال قائلة
إنه
سيتم السماح للطلاب بالعودة إلى الحرم الجامعي لبعض
الطلاب ولكنهم سيقدمون
كل ما تعلموه عبر الإنترنت فقط
جامعة برينستون تقول أيضًا
أن معظم  سيكون التعلم عبر الإنترنت
أيضًا ،
لذا فإن هؤلاء الطلاب هناك حقًا الكثير
من الخوف والقلق وعدم اليقين
بشأن ما يحدث بالضبط هنا ،
وهناك أكثر من مليون
طالب دولي يأتون إلى
هذا البلد كل عام للمشاركة
في الدراسات في الجامعات عبر
البلد الذي يأتون منه في
الغالب من الصين وكوريا الجنوبية والمملكة
العربية
السعودية وكندا يتساءل معظمهم عن ماذا
يحدث هنا إذا جاءوا إلى هذا
البلد وإذا تم تقديم فصولهم عبر الإنترنت في البداية
ولكن بعد ذلك ربما يزداد الوباء
سوءًا وتعود بعض هذه الجامعات
إلى الفصول الدراسية عبر الإنترنت فقط ،
فسيتعين عليهم العودة إلى وطنهم
ماذا لو لم يتمكنوا من ذلك  عد إلى وطنهم ،
لذلك هناك الكثير من عدم اليقين
الذي تعرفه على الرغم من أن
الوضع الراهن بالنسبة للجليد ، فإن إرشاداتهم
بشكل عام
هي أن الطلاب الدوليين
القادمين إلى هذا البلد لا يمكنهم
أخذ دروس عبر الإنترنت فقط ولكنهم
لا يخفون خلال هذا الوباء  كما
اعتقد بعض الناس أنهم قد يكونون
كذلك ، فهذه إرشادات صارمة للغاية هنا
وأنت تعرف كيم ، هذا هو في الحقيقة مجرد
أحدث
قيود على الهجرة القانونية
التي فرضتها الإدارة الرابحة
، كان الشهر الماضي فقط هو أن الإدارة الرابحة
علقت
التأشيرات المتعلقة بالتوظيف والآن
يبدو أن ذلك
إنهم متشددون تمامًا عندما يتعلق
الأمر بتأشيرات الطلاب
الذين يقولون إن أيًا من هؤلاء
الطلاب الدوليين لا يمكنهم البقاء هنا
إذا كانت هذه الجامعات تقدم دورات عبر الإنترنت
فقط